let's go
all right
oh this feels good
[Music]
hello everybody Welcome All
right take title Tuesday will be
beginning very shortly
okay title Tuesday will start in right
now oh come on
okay here's round one
okay guys here we go sorry I started a
little bit late
I'm in stress City right now let me know
how you can how whether you can hear me
well
not too many expectations for today I'm
just gonna try to play decently
yeah I've got a major headache so
hopefully I don't I get over 50 percent
oh your car's not playing
foreign
I think Bishop D4 and then that's all I
know
and queen A5 is a move here
this is still Theory
um don't remember what Black's main move
is here
I think yeah 90s
probably not a move
I think A5 I'm supposed to go
grab my water
[Music]
okay
maybe Queen D2 I should have played
in 95 you can't play Knights C5 I'll go
Bishop F3 and the only issue is he might
be able to trade the darksword Bishops
which is typically not in Wade's favor
yeah the course is up for sale
as you guys already know Bortnick and I
will be holding a Arena
themed tournament after at 7 30 PM 30
minutes after title Tuesday ends
um to sign up you need to join
bortnick's club and then the join the
sign ups will open at 6 33 an hour
before the tournament starts the top
finishers receive a course it'll be
really fun boarding and I will both be
playing in it that'll be a nice little
way to reinvigorate some
hype around the course
I know that some people have asked for
refunds or some for completely
legitimate reasons in the last couple of
weeks I've been slow to give out refund
I will be doing that later today as well
so if you're you know
I'm you know if you're listening and you
requested a refund for no reason then I
will still be giving you that refund but
just please be patient
I mean we've gotten a couple we expected
that but I'm again I'm not trying to
scam anybody I just have been
ridiculously busy
so the horse will be on sale for 24
hours
okay let's focus on the games
link the the club sign up is in the link
such as ex-clamp course tournament and
then follow the link to the club sign up
and then the tournament sign up link
will open an hour before the tournament
starts
okay we're just making moves here
oh come on
this blank is wrong I'm updated after
this game
I gotta killer thank you
yes sir I have a raging headache today
I'm like trying to do 400 things before
I leave for Oslo tomorrow
I'm very stressful so we're just gonna
chill
um chest kid cup
is happening in Oslo
so you guys you know the CCC tournaments
have you ever seen the commentary with
Tanya and it has from that studio you
know what I'm talking about there have
been like two of them so far so this
next one the finals I'll be commentating
with Canty owl and Tanya
foreign
day but I'm flying in on the morning of
the 18th I'm leaving New Jersey tomorrow
at 6 pm
but by the time my flight gets in it'll
be this it'll be the 18th
[Music]
don't like my position here what else is
now right
[Music]
Oslo is in Norway
this guy is good in time pressure
but if he brings himself down to two
seconds he'll lose on time
okay
[Music]
I mean I don't know what he's doing
you can't just get you can't get
yourself to one second in five moves
hey Roger
foreign
[Music]
means coal means everything I think
first I can get top five
here everybody a lot of words similar
to Malik I think Malik means okay
foreign
words I think
on that you know
it's also a first name
Malik Monk Is King Monk
that's actually funny Monk
so hard to see
from the moment
scrubs are more than welcome
10 bucks from Raiden range thank you
has to be winning but I never know how
to actually finish these games ever
know how to finish this
thinking
I mean I see a move that's tempting and
it doesn't work and I keep getting stuck
on it tonight G4
3 is
definitely a bad move but I don't see
anything else
[Music]
goes to G4 wow I was not expecting it
was in G3
I guess he wants Rook G3
it requires it's not unrated and yes the
theme tournament requires you to play
the Chihuahua that's kind of the point
it's unrated obviously because the theme
tournaments can't be rated because you
have to play a certain opening
yeah I'm starting to
still bike is better now is this
I always get out playing
always
get it I'm just can't find moves
I should still be okay I mean this
should not be worse for black
I'm Gonna Come
's Queen takes D6 I think is good for
black for 96.
3 okay have to have to here
[Music]
you two
what do I have here
nothing okay
G5 Maybe
four at the night
[Music]
I mean without increment again it's the
game is over every game I would be over
in that increment
literally the game's over that increment
okay I like the look of Knight D3
I don't know if it works tactically but
I'll try
oof
yeah I don't trap his Queen actually
sadly
I have nothing
this is domination on all fronts but I
have no actual move
and now he gives 95 and wins
I was I wonder how is this possible
I can try a second though nothing works
I mean I have to try to sack my queen
only chance
[Music]
I don't understand this this is some
kind of curse
and it's like I'm it's like I'm cursed
types of games
trying to create complications here get
him to flag
but no
yes oh my gosh only way that I can win
these games is by flagging
you know what it is I need to work on
it's like
I just I can't find him maybe I wasn't
that much better to begin maybe my
mistake was assuming I was winning yeah
it's equal actually I missed evaluated
this I was looking for a win and I
should just play chess
I am better after Knight A4
I am better after Knight A4 yeah sure
I'm already worse
so I I just
I mean you can't really blame me for
assuming that this position is winning
it looks it looks so dominant for black
I'm I have like ideal pieces but I just
don't have a clear way to break through
it's weird
but somehow I hesitate a lot more than I
would in normal games because I know in
normal games I can flag him if you
refute to my one that's honestly the
root of the problem
root of the problem is that
um in a three plus zero game I would
onboarding one again very nice
I would I would just play something and
my opponent would think until they've
got 20 seconds and the game would be
over because I would just flag them
easily
Abby just hung made in one of board Nick
oh you beat Fabby oh my gosh
we did hangman in one but okay he was
much worse now it's that's misleading he
was getting outplayed wow gordonic beat
Fabian ninja Bobble London awesome
okay so pretty good score actually seven
out of nine is very respectable but it's
not gonna win the tournament it is a
draw this is a draw with best play
Knight versus Rook as a draw
that's good to know it's actually quite
an easy draw
when kramnik okay
yeah I've waited for this long time
okay let's actually try to give him a
good game
for some Revenge
[Music]
all right there's a Susan
MP3
I don't remember this one I mean this is
not a theoretical line at all he's
playing
some random silly in line
I'm comfortable for black actually
[Music]
foreign
trying to stop G5 which is very good
[Music]
I think what did I think
problem is an ipd7 you can sack on it
East
okay I'll take the plunge I'll allow
Bishop E6 otherwise otherwise I just
can't get my pieces
positions
but it's a good one
really good
[Music]
I missed
now 984
not fun position but I do have some
counter playing with because it was very
positional
okay I have to Castle and try to meet
him in this awesome castles
[Music]
if I don't like E5
foreign
[Music]
thank you
I didn't
do this
[Music]
night
thank you
[Music]
foreign
oh this feels good
yeah that's freaking right anything to
say increment Andes
Mr and Mrs Mr and Mrs I can't play with
increment
certain misses I can't play with
increment are silent for once
okay let's win the last one or at least
try
that was a nice one
[Music]
yeah Queen H4 is really beautiful this
is just a sexy move I also had Rook T5
now notice
[Music]
I mean obviously here you should have
take I mean he had some more practical
chances he wondered Rook D4 takes A4 but
nice
foreign
yeah there are some nice tactics there
if I win the last one I get I get into
the top five I have no chances to win
the tournament
but I do have a nice chance to win
to get into the top five
[Music]
okay when I said Revenge
uh when I said Revenge I meant for our
classical game
we played a classical game in 201
he's obviously beatable
I don't know why I put the elephant
maybe I should play Knight F3 or so limo
yeah this line I I know pretty well
actually
Jones played it against okay so clearly
sure he's got to looked it up before
she was supposed to go A6 and then D4
foreign
I have my B5 as a candidate let's not
take too long calculate C4
yeah I know before it doesn't work okay
um
55 then
it's 985 I have Knight A7
I'm trying to find a move against Queen
E7
I have some promising lines there but I
don't see open
[Music]
he's using up a lot of clock here I
don't see a move for him
simply don't see him and he might have
to move his nobody even if he moves his
Knight it's bad he might have to play 95
but I don't see what he does after
Knight Ace then
okay we need someone played so I have
c496 then he gives up his Queen and it's
not it's obviously not winning
and there's 92 in the game
I don't give a damn I'm gonna play it I
don't give a
so from Knight A3 was also possible the
good thing about this move is I have two
directions I can go in
I'm Gonna Keep the pressure going on his
clock
okay what if I go here
oh I should have gone to E4 I should
have gone id4
because that was sloppy that was very
sloppy right there very sloppy
I'm just gonna keep playing fast no
worries I'm still winning
still winning
I think I'm still winning at least
in a torizaga is unbelievably tricky
though so let's
let's just continue playing like I don't
give a damn
freaking world oh he has this move
I don't care
we go out go out here and meet him
b4's in my pocket
[Music]
it takes six Bishop D6 where's the win
here there is a win I'm sure where is it
we get nervous here
[Music]
A7 doesn't work how is this not just all
over on the spot look at this position
C4 no
56 he moves his King to descending
okay
just don't see it I guess I can go here
make him think a little bit longer I
mean he has to think here
I don't see a move for him again but I'm
sure he has one and he's gonna find it
so we have to be precise here
okay rebuilding the time Advantage here
Rook d8 I have Rook D5
and he doesn't see a movie either he
goes Queen D7 which I saw
can't I take
a plane I have to watch the back rank
mate
obviously I screwed this up but I'm
still really winning
four maybe
four is a little bit
iffy
what if I go like that no shits and he's
gonna Knight I up then I Bishop C5
it's so confusing figure even figure out
a move here
no that was not the way
ah where is it
oh my gosh
hi blender
I did didn't I
where's the freaking win
where is the wind
I can
I mean I can play it some no
going through here
oh Panic Don't Panic it's fine
here
no Chuck there we go there we go
I didn't panic I just sat there until I
found the win
let's go
that's why I built up that time
Advantage so I could do this
come on Sasha come on Sasha you got this
if Sasha wins this game he wins the
tournament
I had a lot of wins to listen listen
when you when you're sitting there and
your time is ticking and you know it's a
lot is on the line it's harder than it
seems it's so easy to screw this
position up let's go Sasha you got this
he's gonna win Sasha's gonna win this
he's gonna win title Tuesday
oh my God this would be awesome
come on come on couple more moves couple
more moves Knight D6 and it's over he's
got it boarding's got a 96 96 come on no
yes he's got it wardnick wins title
Tuesday
clear first with 10 out of 11.
and I've got terrible tie breaks with 9
out of 11. I'm gonna tie for second no
time for third
but I passed carwana and stuff
yeah amazing stuff for oh this might be
a drone too
why is he going for it
yeah 10 out of 11 is unbelievable
oh this freaking on Dragon's gonna win
the guy had like 15 draws
okay and draken passes me as well
because he has better tie breaks
but still I'm very happy with the end of
the tournament
given my like condition right now I I
won the last five
I'll take it
everyone's happy
boardnik wins clear first so
I mean I've got a pretty bad headache
and I'm just tired in general
should not have blundered the second
game I mean I should I should be a
billionaire and
I have seven wives like a lot of things
should be the case
yeah I think 11 out of 11 has happened
browser okay the arena happens in 24
minutes
so folks sign up for the arena
okay I got fifth
but I actually get a prize not bad I
actually have pretty good tie breaks I
mean I could have gotten third if I
didn't
if I'm drinking a drawn I would have
gotten fourth
but
no this is really good this is a really
good performance we both made the top
five board Nick wins
and I beat kramnik
it's always good
the prize money is
easy because it's that freaking title
Tuesday
yeah I was getting crushed by cram Nook
and then and then suddenly things turned
around he just let me let me finish my
development
and once I started getting the dark
squares
the best thing about this game is that I
actually outplayed him positionally
which always feels good
then you know the whole the whole the
whole I'm just tactics narrative is not
always the case like I can actually play
some good positional moves from time to
time
here I was playing almost perfectly I
think
but yeah I'm proud of Ward Nick that's
awesome
first place a thousand dollars
you gotta finally got a good pairing in
the last round usually Sasha gets
screwed over with pairings
usually usually boarding gets really
screwed with pairings
but in the last round he got a really
really good pairing
well what do you mean by that I mean a
thousand bucks for first is okay it's an
online tournament that happens every
week
it would be nice if if what I would
prefer is that the prices were more
evenly spread out and that there would
be maybe like at least 100 bucks for the
first top five finishers
yeah I mean a thousand bucks given how
stacked the tournament is is a joke but
still I mean I'm
at least it gives people a chance to
support their income online you got to
be reasonable
[Music]